theranos founder elizabeth holmes was
once on top of the tech world big time
and now she is back in the headlines
this morning she promised a revolution
in medical testing charming silicon
valley investors and the media along the
way
now holmes and the company's former
president are accused of falsely
claiming their technology could
accurately perform lab tests with just a
few drops of blood
both have pleaded not guilty to multiple
counts of wire fraud holmes is due in
federal court later today for jury
selection in her trial meg oliver is
here now to show us her potential
defense strategy meg this is an
interesting twist good morning to you
good morning gail according to recently
unsealed court documents elizabeth
holmes does plan to take the stand and
her attorneys hope to show that her
former business partner and boyfriend
emotionally and sexually abused holmes
for years they'll argue that the alleged
abuse clouded their client's judgment
during the time she's accused of
committing fraud we'd like to see a
world in which every person
gets access to this type of basic
testing
once hailed the next steve jobs
elizabeth holmes promised to
revolutionize health care with just a
prick of a finger and a few drops of
blood the stanford university dropout
who founded theranos at 19 claimed a
miniature blood analyzer like this one
could test for everything from
cholesterol to cancer the idea exploded
with theranos raising hundreds of
millions of dollars from big name
investors holmes graced magazine covers
drew attention from politicians and
watched our company's valuation soar to
9 billion
in 2015 she spoke to nora o'donnell for
cbs this morning
what about those who say that's not
enough blood to do all the tests that
need to be done especially if someone's
very sick and you're trying to figure
out what it is
every time you create something new
there should be questions and to me
that's a sign that you've actually done
something that
is transformative
but just six months later then wall
street journal reporter john kerry
revealed the technology didn't actually
work and the company ran many of its
tests on third party machines
when did you first suspect something was
off with their nose you know from the
moment i learned about elizabeth holmes
i think i was suspicious how are you
doing following an investigation federal
regulators forced their nose to close
its labs and void nearly a million test
results one patient
was told by theranost that she was hiv
positive when in fact she was perfectly
healthy several other patients were told
that they were no longer pregnant when
their pregnancies were perfectly viable
so that's going to be powerful testimony
court documents reveal holmes will
likely try to pin the blame on
ex-boyfriend and former theranos
president sunny belwani claiming he
abused her and controlled everything
from what she ate how she dressed and
who she could interact with
what do you think her tone will be like
in the courtroom her lawyers have told
the judge she really doesn't want to
wear a mask so that that tells you that
uh
her tactic or at least one of her
tactics is going to be to try to draw
the jury's sympathy i can't predict
what's going to happen i think
i wouldn't put it past her to
you know
get the jury to eat out of her hand
since being charged holmes has gotten
married and had a baby last month
attorneys for sunny belwani have called
homes allegations salacious and
inflammatory insisted he be tried
separately which will happen next year
attorneys for both parties did not
return a request for a comment it's
definitely salacious
i mean there's a financial part of it a
lot of money was involved there's the
ethical part of it we heard some of the
accusations but there's also just like
the human fascination her voice change
you know the steve jobs look kind of
fragile rock thing she had going yeah
and let's not forget henry kissinger
george schultz former senator sam nunn
general james mattis they all sat on the
board of theranos a lot of people
were kicking in yeah taking it it's
probably a better way that's very
charming yeah captivating is a very good
word but i highly recommend john's book
bad blood excellent you read that book
and
your jaw drops after you covering the
story and meeting her and talking to her
and then reading his book and that
documentary really really well done what
do they say out there in silicon valley
fake it till you make it right but not
really fake
yeah yeah especially those folks who
were told that they were not pregnant or
officers
that is just terrible heartless
it's going to be a very interesting
trial thank you meg you're welcome good
to see you